all right well for people who are
joining us on this livestream this is
another in a long series of meetings
about chemistry functionality for often
language and it's been a little while
since we looked at this so let's get
going here um Jason I think that's you
making background noise okay so where do
we want to start yeah with uh with the
the input form for the molecule it's
still let's see I've kept things rather
agnostic I could still change the the
full form the evaluated form for the
molecule but I think that we've set up
on something that that is that that is
workable this is different from what
we've seen before I mean so it's not
just a picture of the molecule it's this
it's this whole object right so it
produces in the in the notebook it
formats as a summary box in the future
this could I thought that's not what
we'd agreed didn't we go through this
like a month or two ago Lucy I don't
called settling on I mean settling on
anything I've recall that we we decided
we wanted to in the to improve it but we
didn't settle on anything what I like
about graph for mesh region when they
format is something in a notebook is
that they've they're fully integrated
you've got context menus or perhaps
attached cells and all this stuff you
don't do you put something like Guelph I
don't think we have that yet so for
graph we don't have attached cells but
we have context menus that are very
interactive with a graph and that's I
have the functionality that I could hook
up to that I just have to don't have the
no idea we had this so I mean I can
imagine how I think you've said that
every time Stephan every time you've
seen it and played with it you've said
the exact same thing but maybe that's a
sign that we need something more
discoverable right so what it is what it
does is to change the icon right the
mouse pointer is different in a graph
object and we will have an excel is the
plan eventually just as we did for
meshes but what about I mean the attach
sulfur for like image 3ds has been
images has been there for a while I mean
there's obviously a technology for doing
that is that not easy to hook into not
super easy but it's you know and the
image processing team is going to take
for developing that attached cell this
one is the one for meshes is wholly
developed with Charles and and the team
the technologies is fine it's just that
the process of actually designing it
takes some time that's kind of fanatic
well it's not fully top level at this
point right yeah I mean there is yeah
that's the issue
it's sort of an x-ray so there's it's
not pure I mean it's pure top level but
the Fontan need to detect that that cell
is a sin as a specific cell so you need
to have you talked to Lou and John about
what's actually involved in this I've
done that before yes I mean you know
they say the goal is to make it top okay
queued up over there
no I I don't understand that because
I've heard about this for other purposes
about attach cells when did you last ask
them I mean when I was designing is not
a matter of implementation I mean a
wider code on content is not a problem
of that his movie for us is more matter
of time on designing - cell what is it
what is the problem is the problem doing
the UX design the attached cell or is
the problem hooking up the attached cell
or is the problem rights a little bit of
both okay because it's non-trivial to
make a good attached cell it takes many
iterations to make it really good
your initial design is never good but
then you iterate your way to something
that's pretty powerful
all right but so do you have any draft
of an attached self or graph yes we do
maybe we should look at it sometime
maybe we can help move it forward more
quickly that's not the issue Stephen
it's capacity okay but the question is
what you've said is that it's effort to
design the attached cell but you need
iterate implementation to be able to do
that it doesn't help so much to have
just sort of a you know an opinion based
on nothing so to speak
you know nobody's gonna discover this
menu I mean I said he didn't know that's
why we planned to do the attach cells
okay okay fine okay this is the only
thing we had maybe after we've had all
this discussion I'll remember it for
next time so so basically I don't want
to focus on great on the the formatting
of the molecule until we really have the
the innards of it till we have a robust
object because I'm really the only one
who's who's kind of working on this so
so I mean could you so try to avoid that
background noise it really would be good
sorry I'm just yeah okay um now we've
got heavy breathing Michael um okay
so back to this great so so it formats
as a summary box it tells you the
formula of the number of atoms I can put
in the molecular weight if you if you
click below the fold it can show the
smiles string okay so but in general
like these there's no coal on there
there's no space there come on we gotta
clean that up
yes right and what are you gonna do it
fees are much longer the currently it
just it's if they get too long they fold
over I mean they fold over how do they
fold very ugly li okay so that's not
going to cut it is it so how do we
generate a more interesting molecule if
I say something like have you hooked up
if I say control equals caffeine or
something will I be able to get
something that is consistent with that
how do I get this thing here so so I
believe you're going to need to evaluate
the cells at the very top of the agenda
and then for now you have to get
chemistry backtick okay URLs saved
transferred a partial file that says and
what that means failed okay do I need to
be in a prototype build these will work
in the prototype built they just won't
have the changes I made today but this
is I'm running this an 11-3 so that's
bold
yeah no it definitely what okay so it
needs to be in prototype build correct
yeah or any 12 well which is better at
non prototype that way you can install
the package and get today the changes I
made today for the as it was hastily but
the way you would make a molecule out of
that entity is just just by feeling some
bug here which
for a couple of days about system
asymptotic some there's a point for it
no I know I've since we have Roger here
I wonder if he's aware of it yeah I
reported it to and it is something about
I mean it's reported it's known it's
something about the forget what it was
function pack that that scrapes the
information for something occur
something okay so how do I get your
molecule thing
Jason sorry I was muted copy those into
the into the version Twitter into the
other notebook and then they should
evaluate and if not then the meeting
could be much shorter I guess okay
so then when I evaluate this what am I
going to get am I gonna get this
molecule this chemical entity and then
how do I get the actual molecule of it
you love that yes okay okay that's good
all right so now I say molecule of this
cool and so in that case because we have
the data in the in the knowledge base it
grabbed the the coordinates from the
molecule and the structure diagram
coordinates but normally if you just
create a molecule from a name or a smile
string those aren't included in the
expression okay all right so let's sum
okay how do I get it can I just enter a
smile string I want to enter a smile
string here we go okay how do I turn
that into a molecule doctor so a
molecule of that exactly okay so listen
there's there's a design and we have
anybody from design look at this yet no
okay should we get somebody from design
on here right now
I mean the first of all this thing has
to be anchored at the top when making
sense yeah concentrate in this thing and
I don't know why there's so much space
at the bottom here I think you're
centering it you should just anchor it's
at the top okay I could set up a meeting
with with Jeremy you don't need to do
that I'm going to tell you that that's
what you need to do here you just anchor
it at the top okay yeah um and yeah you
probably should set up a meeting with
Jeremy I think this this width here is
slightly wrong and so on okay and make
sure that this that there the right
space is there but now hide away in a
smile string just to remind me how to
get something more interesting
can I have brackets and things like that
in here so what
so brackets will create a branch so they
should be parentheses and so that's a
case I could come up with a better error
message from the just from doing um reg
X on it oh that's cool that's really
cool wow this is fun and if you look in
the chat window I just pasted a list of
ten random rather in long smile strings
that you could play with if you like
okay so each one of these it's going to
turn into a molecule okay that's cool
alright so now what can I do with one of
these molecules so let's take this
molecule here for example right so so
it's evaluatable you should be able to
copy paste it and why you can do that
but what would I do with it
I've got a molecule how do I find the
molecular weight of this thing so ask it
for the string value molecular mass nice
okay so what else can i compute here
yeah also so in so there's a nice regex
for for telling whether something is a
possible smiles in cheese are nice
because they always start with in chi
equals right so so it's the canonical
form gonna be this or is the canonical
form going to be something with the
entities this is the canonical form that
i've that we're working with now but i
thought we have discussed having a form
that involves entities here or is that
wrong well so the only issue there is
that that you can't have an element
entity that has a charger that has
another property
we could we discussed using entity
instance but it just seemed too
cumbersome to but no it's very important
we have the right chemical form
otherwise comparisons are not gonna work
I'm going forward we don't want to have
had the wrong canonical form rate but I
think having something that has deeply
inside entities entities that are also
questionable if they're of the right
type here I fearful okay element is
again more a bike object it's not a war
atom fair enough
and I mean it's to have that as an
additional information about it if we
know it what is dead if if we know what
the entity is as well that will be
useful yes right I mean it's not it's
it's more optional it's not required
right so in addition to molecule amass
something that says something about
elements that it contains so so we have
the atom list function that where you
can ask for atoms of the of the molecule
and you can ask for atoms the magic
pattern and then function list mm-hmm so
Adam lists percent eleven and then the
second argument can be a pattern right
an atom pattern so it could be just the
string capital o is the second argument
okay but but there should be a way to
get this out as entities right so so the
second argument can be a list also where
pattern goes to string and the string
right now I have those two indices or
formal charges or something welcome and
what about entities right so it could be
entities that didn't work okay that
blank arrow formal charges what should
work or just try capital o there but
blank should work I don't understand
that what did I just do okay not just
showing me oh right and by the way where
are they I mean if these things are
supposed to have annotation beyond just
the atom type of some kind of charge
information where is it
right so we would okay so those inputs
should work and I'm sorry that they
don't at the moment but that's the
syntax that would would work and so so
anything else in an atom besides the the
atomic symbol is as a list of rules so
form atom o formal charge goes to one
mass number goes to fourteen okay so
what is this doing here so Carl Center
is eight
okay so then indexing into here so I
could have named these things and had
this be an association instead of a five
there will be a name of an atom here
right right so you could have listed the
first the the atoms could be a name goes
then I would refer to them I mean the
fact that these are indexed by numbers
is purely because this happens to be a
list with numerical indices right right
okay so then I could take I see so I
could say molecule plot percent eleven
that was a very ugly object I mean way
it's too way too big right so you need
the right heuristic to decide the size
yes maybe Charles could comment on that
for what we've done with graphs I mean
fundamentally this should be you should
try to default to have a font size
that's about the standard font size for
these you know if there was a font have
the font size be about the standard font
size unless it gets too big in which
case you're going to have to go smaller
with these things right am I making
sense yes
so never get bigger by default then the
standard font size would be make sense
yes so so I had a heuristic but it was
it was doing very poorly so I've removed
it for now so that's the heuristic that
you need is you need something where the
size of the font would be about the
standard font size makes sense
yes um and presumably image size will
work here correct yes okay but the
question for this is do we really want
these things to scale up do we want
those fonts to scale up like that I
doubt that we want that maybe we do so
that that's an area where I am a little
bit out of my element I when I draw
these things I have to so if you see the
oh where the lines come into the oh but
they stop what I do is I estimate the
the size that that work Charles what can
you say about that
what for use my internal dynamic in
labor law so I can show him how we do
that for graph so we control the
distance I mean the 1,400 of the
distance at the right position okay
sounds like the right thing to do here I
mean these look pretty decent though
okay what about if I want to do 3d can I
do molecule plot 3d yeah yeah and when
you do that it's just it's going to
generate the coordinates on the fly for
them now that's very space-age I mean
that's very impressive why is there so
much space around the molecule in this
dimension so in chemical data we make or
an alpha we say shrink wrap method goes
to shrink wrap goes to true but for this
I have taken the the so far I add very
few options to the result in graphics 3d
but not your shrink web experience when
you touch it is too unpleasant yeah I'd
agree but is this one this looks bigger
even than its spherical region
you see what I'm saying there's
something wrong here it's a Cecchetti
there's nothing but Jason they're
special yeah but Stephen is right there
could be
who knows if someone put some padding in
there yeah something is we just called a
regular molecule a 3d so it's more a
revision of moloch molecule what 3d
right so it's very there is a molecule
plant 3d in the layout there was written
when chemical data was introduced and
what I've got is basically rewritten it
but using some of the oh yeah I'm
telling you there's something wrong here
okay so I don't know what it is but
there's something wrong with the with
the it could be the manually specified
viewpoints maybe remember weeks ago we
went to another B data sweetie and it's
just it's just a terrific Spiritist okay
well so there's something wrong then we
so this is an issue for who for you to
or for Brett yeah okay you so have been
working on updating the graphic on doing
a search as we used for Ponto so it's
possible that there is some side effects
as well so if I take this and I copy it
into an older version that should be the
right that should do the right thing
right still got that problem let me ask
if somebody can find you so so let's see
so another thing that you can do with
molecule plot is the second argument is
the highlights things that you want to
highlight okay but we have a question on
the live stream asking would arrow keys
rotate around the x and z axes x or z
axes we don't really have a sway to do
structured rotation we really only have
free you know is that something
chemistry people care about to be able
to do rotation around specific galaxies
well so one of the popular programs that
people use to look at these is is called
a Gaudreau and they've got this really
neat thing where you right-click and
remove and it shows it changes the
center of rotation to where you clicked
and it and their modifiers like shift or
what not to to change the action of
rotation whether it's around a fixed
axis or or whatnot I don't know all the
details but and that that's fairly
common with a number of the molecular
modeling packages that sort of
capability but is that what people want
is that they lock to a particular atom
and rotate around that
or is it is that some reason why one
cares about specifically X and Z
rotation sometimes about X and Z es z
being the canonical vertical axis as it
were you you basically want to spin it
like a top but slowly so you can see
what's going on fixing the rotation
around a specific atom is something that
would be very useful you're interested
in them for some reason it's part of an
active site in a molecule or something
like that or it's the part that's
binding to the active site or it's a
reaction center so those kinds of issues
for 3d graphics
I wonder what Roger can you comment on
that I mean is that we haven't really
had that issue for our traditional 3d
graphics we I mean we have prototypes we
have prototypes of all of that but it
it's no it's what you have there is
basically dragging on a sphere so you
can rotate in any possible direction
it's the default
there's a slightly different one for 3d
it uses a different rotation controller
to maintain right to maintain vertical
he'll maintain the vertical right right
right um but so we already have
experience with different rotation
controllers and that this thing here
right now molecule plot is generating
like graph plot is generating a it is
not generating a special molecule thing
it is simply generating graphics
correct but presumably presumably plot
3d is also just generating graphics 3d
so it must have some special option to
specify the rotation controller yes yeah
okay so that's something we could do
again here if we could figure out the
appropriate rotation controller yeah but
it sort of has to be the kind of a joint
project with you two and so on yeah I
know
he also on the live stream Michael Hale
is pointing out that you know there are
things where you start spinning it and
it keeps on spinning yeah we considered
that years ago for our 3d graphics and
we never implemented that um so
something interesting you could do if
you go up to the the 2d plot where you
say molecule clawed percent 11 and give
it a second argument just the word bond
sorry its ahead so bond will specify an
unspecified type of bond two arguments
1st argument is a blank second argument
is a capital o right and so if you
change that bond it to be double bond
and it should only highlight just the
one bond okay that's cool so this is
different semantics for what we do for
highlighting for plots for example but
we don't have highlighting for I mean we
have highlight graph and we have
highlight image which are highlighting
functions and in those the highlights
are internal to the expression right I
mean it's the or maybe no no you can
like so you can you can wrap your
vertices in and wrappers to make them
highlight it but yeah exactly yeah and
you're looking at the screen yeah yes
yeah so we have this graphics 3d object
and we want to know why the thing is is
has so much empty space around it seems
to be much bigger than the cert than the
enclosing sphere Jim any thoughts about
that yes because of the bounding box it
has some if you visualize the bounding
box so you are seeing mmm yeah okay so
that's crazy in my opinion we have a
option called cigarette that's different
but I mean so hold on what we want is
something which has the sphere but not
the cuboid nodes it leaves space for the
sphere but does not leave space for the
cuboid so you want a smaller bounding
well though it's there's no reason to
have if you're not showing the box I
don't see a reason to leave space for
the box I leave there's a reason to
leave space for the surrounding sphere
but not for the corners of the box do
you get what I'm saying nobody when
boxed is false I don't understand why it
leaves extra space for the box because
it doesn't compute more precisely than
bounding box
that this is a very compact molecule and
if you take something that's like a
hydrocarbon a little long-chain you know
it's like looking at a rod and what's
appropriate then when you that's very
different look at that in a second but
hold on a second I'm trying to
understand from you to the statement
Roger made is we're not computing the
bounding sphere but that can't be
correct yeah right currently if so what
is doing here it looks to me it's
computing the bounding sphere for the
bounding box not for the material here
now for the but for the content right
which is a harder problem okay in this
case for this domain it's not that hard
in fact we have it in a bounding region
will can give you that very efficiently
this yeah so if you just have a set of
points which you have here somebody's
sending me something in chat what is
this oh he's sending me a long
hydrocarbon here why does it curl itself
up like that why is it not just straight
it's not physically correct
Jason sorry I forgot that I was muted
there um let's see so that would be yeah
so that's that would be correct you you
expect a molecule like that to be floppy
is that what we would describe it well I
know that but I know that but well what
the heck just happened that why did it
suddenly get so small well so that one's
got a very rectangular box like one of
the dimensions is much different than
the others and so I think so it does I
mean okay so the basic problem here is
an algorithmic problem that you su
doesn't know what the genuine sphere
around the contents are is that correct
you two actually we can compute it that
it just the cost is too expensive but
you don't have to do it once and for all
right you only have to do it once you
have to know what the center of the
sphere is no you have to do it even want
yes sure one rotation you have to
consider it because the viewpoint
changes everything's changed I don't
understand that you have a physical
sphere that given the coordinates here
there is a center and there's a sphere
why do you need to recompute that if you
change the viewpoint it is it's in 3d
space the sphere is in 3d space yes just
like you visualize that the box that's X
Y Z range is but there are some corners
there if you it's not if not visualized
it's empty and if you the viewpoint is
different to the empty space or be
different so what you mean oh I
understand but we're saying we don't
want the box we're saying consider only
the content work out the physical
bounding sphere around the content
given a certain view center
or even the eyes is that the problem
that you're looking at a particular
Center and that defines the center of
the sphere right yeah Roger helped me
out here am i yeah no you
you're right Stephen what if one could
compute it once and for all like in this
said it's a set of points it's very
cheap to compute that the sort of
minimum volume bounding sphere and but
but we don't have that right now so it
would be an extension to what we do I'm
pretty sure we do not have okay so fine
so this would be an extension of
graphics 3d to give it the the bounding
sphere so this is like spherical region
but it's a most sophisticated version of
spherical region like for example it
could be spherical region and again
spherical region actually uses the
bounding box is what you're seeing there
I'm saying you know I know so there's
just it's just eight points okay but so
this one will have you know in general
thousands of points I understand I
understand that but what I'm saying is
imagine that a possible setting for
spherical region was the center of the
sire and its radius right but in general
you know if you're gonna do that for all
of 3d graphics it's a longer project
because then you need to sort of how do
you reduce everything to the point case
and you can't reduce everything no no I
realize I realize that but what I'm
saying is you do could support a thing
in spherical region which is you know an
explicit sphere yeah Center yes right in
fact should just be a sphere object you
should be spherical region Aero sphere
of you know Center coma radius and then
this in quick your plot could actually
do that computation yes could no it's
just points right and it can actually
call bounding region which has fast code
for that does that make sense
Jason yes okay that's what I would
suggest you su does that make sense to
you yeah I can make a method to to
visualize only the sphere region instead
of Pawnee parks region so but but
remember there's a spherical region
arrow true or false option right now for
graphics 3d right okay yeah go ahead but
that's very lucky Roger said it's based
on that the bounding box I know I know
I'm saying instead you do this you say
spherical region eros sphere of X 0 y 0
Z 0 right
radius right so you do an explicit you
make the explicit sphere what represents
what's that
so juicer do you understand right now
spherical region goes to true it it uses
the bounding box indent computes the
bounding sphere from that this would say
take the sphere I'm giving you right
even if you're not completely wrong even
I mean that's just whatever you know you
could specify that that is literally
specifying the sphere it's specifying as
far as the rotation controller is
concerned this is the only thing in the
image okay what I'm saying
we we using plot range to provide the
range way to visualize why don't we just
provide the sphere syntax to plot range
what's an interesting idea as well hmm
I think that's a more complicated thing
because that's that's that will be doing
the equivalent so you could equally well
say why not give a region specification
to plot range it's interesting idea
Roger how do we but we usually we have a
region function right yeah but that's
just for this function since graphics is
a much more primitive level yes you know
graphics better be fast or you know and
I think what we should do initially is
to support this as an experimental thing
if I think you should rebrand have this
is a right hand side but I think
initially let's just do this and if it's
range it shouldn't really be ball you
know because you want yes I understand
you want the interior of the ball right
um okay so you to does this make sense
so for now this will simply be a private
piece of communication that we might not
even document for spherical region that
will be used in the molecule plot
function molecule plot 3d functionality
I will make experiment yeah great okay
question for Jason now I used to why
don't you hang around for a little while
longer um question for Jason how did it
determine how to curl this up right so
the method for for generating the
coordinates is is fairly neat it's
so if there's some randomness involved
in it it creates a bounds distance
matrix so for every atom that is bonded
for every bonded pair every
carbon-carbon bond we know that
carbon-carbon bonds tend to be as such
distance apart so the the matrix element
for that is bounded pretty tightly the
okay so this question so is there a
random seeding function of a molecule
plot 3d option there is a random seating
option not for molecule plant 3d fur
from molecule or for embed molecule what
is embed molecule so it's a function
that would take and take a molecule that
doesn't have coordinates in its
expression and it puts the coordinates
in the expression so if I say random
seating here
so here you would want to say molecule
embedding goes to random seating goes to
that but why am I seeing a this must be
a bug in the in the prototype build I'm
seeing a bad cursor okay what well let's
get to that in a minute okay but what
you're basically saying this is an
attempt to make a physical simulation of
this right so if I take the thing I was
doing before where I had this branched
hydrocarbon you're basically saying if I
do that with the branched hydrocarbon I
can say molecule plot 3d of line 9 right
and it's great tell me this is pretty
neat let's see the algorithm for
generating these these coordinates is I
think really cool and then we've got it
does some so it generates random
coordinates that try that fulfill the
bound matrix and then it tries to do a
little bit of cleanup too so that so the
things that are supposed to be planar or
planar and then we've got we've got
additional cleanup capabilities we can
but then apply a force field and find
the local minimum under that force field
what does the force field come from is
it a van der Waals force field or
something else I think Bob is the the so
it's called the murk molecular force
field and it was developed by Bob and
coworkers
well I primarily Tommy Oliver and I
right he
Dean to include me as an author on one
of the six papers because one of the
referees rejected it unless I was
included but anyway that's another story
it's it's it's a hoax law type spring
model for bond stretching and angle
bending it's got a torsional term for
twisting around single bonds it's got
Van der Waals repulsions or attractions
if they get close enough for an on bond
at distances that has electrostatics in
it okay so it's basically DC physics it
is you know it's what is generally
accepted in the field these days how
does it do relative to x-ray
crystallography for something which I
mean actual molecular MCNS it does
fairly well it was actually calibrated
against high level molecular orbital
calculations okay cool um do we get to
move these molecules do we get to have
any mechanism for having these molecules
move move in what way twist around bonds
and things like that well I mean move as
they would heat that would be molecular
dynamics and Jason we don't have
anything for that hooked up do we we
don't have any dynamics at the moment
that is definitely one of the things
that I'd like to do in the next steps
after after first release so just to
understand what we would think would
happen I mean so the physics you just
described sounds like it could perfectly
well have dynamic you know if you've got
a Hookes law and things like that in
there there is presumably a you know a
Lagrangian and all that kind of thing
you could compute what happened yes
definitely definitely and is it
realistic to do that I mean and they
became is Stewart all the time but so
what would the function look like it
would it would essentially be doing
something like simulated annealing for
optimization but keeping track of the
itinerary and then replay the itinerary
yeah but what would it look like for the
top level
is it like an animated yes it would be a
list animate something like that
I mean an underlying that would be like
a run dynamics function or something
right where you give it an initial
condition and then and then it generates
some kind of object that returns the
snapshots along molecular dynamics not
to be confused with dynamic in the
language right right you're saying is
you have to have an initial
configuration that is okay so there's
two different things one is random heat
both with the thing that's wiggling
around which presumably you know it
Wiggles at a particular temperature this
molecule will would go around the exact
temperature associated with that okay so
that's one thing the other thing is
you've distorted the molecule and now
you want to see what happens when you
kind of let it snap back so to speak is
that right yes yes typically what they
do is they they will supply random
forces on all the atoms to initiate the
dynamics so that it so that it moves
otherwise it's at a potential minimum
and it won't do anything
no I understand but you could also do
that from a heat bath right yes yeah but
then it will keep moving but what I'm
trying to understand is if I if I pull
one of the arms of this thing out all
right if I pull it too hard it's gonna
break really really yes with a molecular
orbital calculation it would say you
dissociate at the bond but with the the
MMFF model it won't it will pull back
okay but so in other words what would
you be so you will be saying to specify
the initial condition you would be
saying take a particular atom and move
it to such and such a position with all
the atoms kind of trailing from that
it's that right you could do that or you
could just plain put it in a bath of
water molecules so that they're all
bouncing around on jiggling around
together and observe what it does over
time there's a confirmation change but
that face if I hate both right yes and
that's what the is usually done I have
not seen applications where somebody
stretches something and then lets it go
except for maybe grins what a grins for
just to see what happens for fun oh I
said
some technical thing like smiles the
vernacular okay
but so so fundamentally it's going to be
some kind of animated molecule plot 3d
where you give it a temperature
basically that right yes and and
sometimes what people do they will heat
it up and then I have a cooling regime a
cooling right yes like annealing to
bring it back down to see what happens
this is often done in the context of
binding to a molecule they also use
Jason what's the thermodynamic cycle
that they use for these things it's like
the Carnot cycle the free energy
perturbation to try to understand
binding energies of ligands in receptors
or enzymes you got me out there Bob
okay all right so listen I have a
question for you to hear okay as I move
this thing around there's this moment
here do you see what happens there it
jiggles see as I'm moving it
continuously but it is not the molecule
I'm moving the controller continuously
as you soon with us I think I saw what
you were mentioning I you stopped moving
it right yeah I stopped moving it now
but did did you soon leave the meeting
looks like he did um okay well that's
another thing to be reported to him
because there's something wrong with the
rotation controller here there was a in
other words a continuous motion is not
leading to continuous change in the in
the molecular orientation I don't know
why probably because something is auto
computing some new view center or some
such other thing is that possible is the
view center fixed
anybody know here Roger do you know
remember right now then
and do you mean to snap to thing or when
you let go of the mouse who do you mean
when now boss let's see whether you su
can rejoin us okay let's keep going here
okay named atoms
oh boy this is something where you're
doing a partial naming but you could do
a full association here with everything
having a name is that correct rate and
it would evaluate to being the canonical
form where they're all atom objects with
the names on the inside just because I
need a canonical form that I can yeah
okay
fine and now we decided that we don't
want braces inside each of these things
like correct yes mainly because there
there wouldn't be any other arguments or
any yeah okay we're not handling three
Center bonds at the moment well what is
that what is a three centered bond
something very exotic that tends to only
happen with with boron stop me from
something is also are viewed that way
sometimes but it's kind of like you know
benzene having a resonance structure or
hybrid structure you know are the bonds
localized or not and that sort of stuff
and with carbo cations a carbon atom
with a positive charge next to a double
bond it tends to share the electrons or
that double bond and they did it it can
be modeled and seems to behave as though
there is a bond shared among three atoms
I say but so wait a minute but in the
case of a benzene ring like that guy
right that what are we doing with the is
that okay this is a naive question but
but these bonds you know they have this
weird you know is it a single bond is it
a double bond thing how is that right
isn't that right or that our aromatic
bond thing those are what the aromatic
bonds represent we have functionality to
just swap it into the we call it the
calculus form where that you have
something right fine okay
did you to rejoin us looks like you did
yes okay so I'm complaining about the
fact that this thing when I move it
isn't doing it now this thing did not
move continuously as I move
mouse and I'm suspecting with its
snapping to some weird that something is
happening with perhaps the view center
or some such other thing yeah you see
there I think it did it again yeah what
the heck is going on there it's moving
it continuously and yet its rotation
axis is changing can you comment on that
do you know what it's doing I mean as I
understand it maybe I need to put the
maybe it will be clearer what's going on
if I put the box around it
well looks then it jumps why does it jog
jumps because it is shrink-wrapping to
the size of the cell correct yeah
okay but otherwise it should be now what
the heck did you just do that again you
can't tell because I'm I think I'm
moving the mouse continuously but I
think this rotation is not happening
continuously should it be should it
should've running very continuously
there might be some bug's here but the
way it looks as it's snapping to change
for example of you Center where is the
view center is at the center of the
bounding box or Center the bounding box
okay
well alright I don't know how we debug
this but but um I think there's
something slightly wrong okay that's
some fine
all right let's let's keep going you
don't have any media you don't
immediately know what's happening
no the center shouldn't be changing but
it's possibly can be impact there okay
all right thanks yeah no thanks thanks a
lot
um okay we're talking about what on
earth is this okay so this is a whole
bunch of okay so this has include
hydrogen's what happens if I say include
hydrogen's to false on the molecule
plots so for molecule plot you could
give it show hydrogen's goes to false
well I know the way what's the don't
include hydrogen's and show hydrogen's
be kind of both different okay here
you're just saying whether or not
they're visible in the other case you're
creating a molecule and you want to know
do you want to create it with the
hydrogen's explicitly present in the
data structure or not explicitly present
in the data structure molecular modelers
often work with molecules without the
hydrogens explicitly present why not
have the same option include hydrogen's
here for the molecule plot 3d as in the
molecule that would be firing that would
be that would be fine yeah I I think not
I think they do two different things one
is for general actually generating
something creating something here we're
just controlling visibility you know
it's like frame true or frame false okay
so could we then have a show hydrogen's
and the molecule as well where it
generates the hydrogen's but does not
show them and it gets carried along and
used for everything downstream until you
change your override it right so that
would be the idea yeah so I was talking
with Michael about whether molecule
itself should take options from molecule
clot or whether it should be in
method option or something like that so
so when you create a molecule you could
control the way that it formats I don't
see why you shouldn't do that does
Michael object to that it seems to me it
is not in heaven think of the sink it's
something that you later do but it's an
advisory thing it's like a graph where
if I'm not mistaken Charles kapap so
answer this
can't you give advisory information on
the on the embedding which is not
relevant to the graph itself right when
you specify a graph charles permission
you mean no coordinate or such a thing
yes
yeah there's a graph layout option it's
included yes I thought that seems
analogous to this doesn't it right but I
mean but I still see them as being two
separate issues right so when you create
the the the two molecules there in the
in include hydrogens section one of them
has a much higher byte count than the
other right one of them has a if you did
length of the first I understand that I
understand we're not saying that show
hydrogen's and include hydrogens should
be the same I'm simply saying I don't
see a problem with including in molecule
things which are relevant for the
rendering of molecule just like graph
has in that are relevant to the
rendering of the graph because it is you
know even though they're not relevant to
the structure of the graph I'm saying
great so so implementation wise do you
do you wrap them all up into one like a
plot options goes to and then a list of
options I don't know I don't know I'm
not I don't think so but but but Charles
Michael is objecting to the fact that it
is not an intrinsic attribute of the
molecule itself things about how it is
displayed a molecule plot 3d which is of
course correct but I'm making the point
that there's been convenient and graph
to give things which are not intrinsic
properties of the graph but are relevant
to its display right there in the graph
object from the beginning
a little as a father dentist regression
die equality yes that is an interesting
question when we say quality I mean this
is this is an object so equality is
relative to what you want to compare
right so to mathematically content or
equality relative to appearance exactly
and that promotes the same problem of
even when you attach property to your
object right so you come to property
change the object by itself like
something that's called molecule not
kind of molecule appearance I feel like
it is too abstract object so it does not
change its identity such things might be
I think you should have you know
visualization properties there as well
in the molecule yeah because you know
for graph you know a pure graph it
doesn't have to display at all
it wouldn't have any embeddings it
wouldn't have anything we do all that
extra work and we did that to get to
networks and get to another set of very
useful things I think molecule plot and
so on will also use to communicate
things so if you want to highlight
things you want to emphasize things
being able to control that it's sort of
important I think
yes it's saving it in the molecule is or
Widow molecule it would be very useful
chemists would really like that
exactly yeah fine so I think I think
Michael is getting somewhat overruled so
if you're saving stuff in a molecule
like kind of what we'll call not
necessarily extraneous but visualization
stuff then when you then you have to ask
the question when you when you delete an
atom when you when you modify it through
all the different modification functions
what do you do for graph about that you
have to take care of it that way you
have the framework of property and it
complicate and you have to implement it
for every single operation
every single change on your object it's
not free so for the time being we could
simply blow it away if you change that
if you change the molecule you blow away
the embedding information that's what I
do right now with meta information so
you can store whatever meta information
you want in a molecule expression but if
you if you delete an atom or something
I'm going to throw it all the way so the
same chemical cue that that's at a
function that I said we're going to talk
about functions in a minute right it's
doesn't seem to be here where is it I
must have I must have it must stop
either but it's supposed to be there
right it's it's like isomorphic graph
queue but it considers properties yet
what is the same chemical so a same
chemical if you have different
embeddings let's imagine that you had a
thing we gave the molecular the atomic
positions and they were different like I
would expect both chemists to say that
they are the same chemical at that point
certainly with proteins if they fold
differently they'll have different
properties and be considered to be
different then the same chemical cue all
they same chemical cue or not as a
molecular model or if I wanted to I I
would distinguish the sameness based on
just the topology of the atoms and the
bonds and the formal charges versus the
3d geometry I'd want to be able to test
those two things separately and get
different notions of equality that makes
sense yell the same chemical cue support
both notions of equality so we should
have a same test option right well the
same yo or it could just have a second
argument but but if you're comparing two
molecules and they're like numerical
roundoff errors of where the atoms are
placed how is it going to know what the
bucket of identical molecules is
so right now it doesn't look at the
coordinates at all no I understand but
will you to do something which did look
at the coordinates how would you deal
with precision ESU's and rotations so a
campus so if you took the same molecule
and rotated it I would still want them
to be considered seemingly a rigid
rotation of the whole mall right exactly
yes so then so then I mean you would
compare the the distance matrix of it or
something like that you put it you know
you align it with the principal moments
of inertia or something yes yeah yeah
that is well of course would have to be
that could be degeneracy and the
principal most yes yeah there were
certainly that and then whether or not
you know even if it was just finer
grained notion of equality when we look
at the embedding as well folding and so
on then you know cumulative topological
things a very quick negative criteria
sure I'm saying not topple augurs week
well there's certainly not gonna be sort
of whatever that other equal is called
right and so so right now with same
chemical Hugh calls isomorphic graph Q
first and if that says no then it
doesn't even look at the names of the
atoms and everything okay fine um
actually have a question on the live
stream about can you read out and it was
also something I was wondering about how
do you read out the positions of all
these atoms so I asked it for its atom
coordinates property of all the number
32 here so okay so if I say and you can
give that a target units option to say
Pico meters or something else and we
default in two angstroms because the SI
people who ultimately failed chemists
have always used we light our bond
lengths to be about one yeah unless
you're what is it a quantum mechanic
chemist and then you talking Bohr's
um so what is that I understand what
this is so this is oh I see this is the
three-dimensional this these are old so
if I said look at this spot 3d or let's
point plot 3d yeah right let's point
plot 3d of the Sun 36 but uh okay great
okay there are nice um and so that's
another spot where you should be able to
say include hydrogen's goes to true or
false when you ask for that property and
it should give you a smaller I say this
hoping that it that I've hooked that up
hydrogen's to false right include
hydrogen's to false then this thing will
be less fluffy but it isn't because I
straight yeah so I there's a mistake
there yeah okay all right this is a hard
to understand stereochemistry story it's
I mean that's that's how every
undergraduate chemist chemistry student
feels as well okay so so the way that we
were taught chemistry stereochemistry in
schools with with very small and small
molecules where you just have four
different substituents on one carbon and
you we make the little models in our
hand to show that they they can be I
have two different configurations that
are that are mirror opposites of each
other and this was the the so we support
a simplified input a user can say
stereotype goes to tetrahedral keiter
sent chiral centers one and Direction is
our in which case we a have to go
through and compute all the other stuff
it makes it a lot
what does our mean so that means that's
some kind of right-handed coordinate
system thing no it is a designation R or
s whether it is right-handed or
left-handed as it were following a
particular
recipe prescribed by three chemists back
in the 1950s and that is related to the
3d geometry and the connection of the
atoms is there a full a name for our
address no well okay they stand for
rectus and sinister okay that's kind of
bizarre as opposed to Dexter and
sinister Oh Dexter oh and levo there's
also DL which has a long history as well
but that has more to do with the optical
rotation of polarized light so
essentially they're the three chemists
cahn-ingold-prelog they came up with
these rules of assigning a priority to
all the atoms in a molecule and when you
look at the the stereochemistry and you
order the atoms in an increasing order
of priority do they show up in clockwise
or counterclockwise and that tells you
whether it's RR s but you know in order
to do that calculation you have to look
at the whole molecule and compute the
priorities but so you you are able to do
that here is that correct so somebody
says Direction arrow or you can
correctly do that and it's it takes a
lot longer so what's written what you're
seeing right there the big list of
associations that defines the
stereochemistry locally rather than
globally and so that's okay fine but so
this is the canonical form you you turn
the global thing into local things right
yes yes so here I don't I wish I had a
better name for those but I have two
different libraries that can generate
coordinates and but I and I queried the
their authors for a method option okay I
would say method goes to and then this
is part of the method option structure
okay and these are incredible names they
are so I even asked I mean I'm on a
mailing list with the authors of both of
those and they asked could you tell me
like what what the method I described
the method so that I can come up with a
name what did they say one said you
could call it the Rd kit method and they
gave me a
to a polish paper we just name it off to
the people somehow yeah I can look into
that yeah I mean these are really
bizarre unless they're very well known
in the industry I think no azar they're
definitely not ones are the one the
court Jen actually produces a nicer plot
and in a lot of cases but it's it can be
very slow so it's not the default well
then maybe we should have a performance
go okay speed or quality that seems like
a reasonable thing to do yeah um let's
do that and they can switch between
those two methods yeah okay I've got you
know it made it note there and I have it
set so that you could add use a graph
embedding method but you're not always
ideal but the golf embedding will have
no physics
well the spring spring embedding I mean
they say physics well sort of yeah I was
just I was actually gonna try gravity
and betting on this one but I didn't
have time
I believe that's still in the prototype
no I think okay I don't think we want a
whole option to specify this I think
this is some kind of method arrow I mean
if I'm not mistaken we could have
something method arrow something like I
guess you can say structure diagram
layout arrow and then I guess what is
the name for these things this these are
graph embedding methods but what do we
call those in the graph system so grass
layout those are the vertex the vertex
component of the graph layout no I
understand that but I'm asking in the
options to graph what do we call the
option whose right hand side is spring
embedding there's a graph layout it's
graph layout or its
it's actually a vertex layout so you
have to gruffly outreaches the whole
general process and then you have the
vertex layout fork is meant for the
vertex is that what these are is vertex
layout yes
so it's not correct is it to say I mean
shouldn't it be then vertex layout or is
that not correct I mean it doesn't sound
a little funny for a chemical it's
making a graph of the chemical yeah this
is the 2d which is very graph like don't
think it makes it off right I mean it
just makes it does not make it coffee it
is the sense okay fair enough
well then this is basically some kind of
layout method that's right but I I like
it I just chose structure diagram layout
because it makes it clear that it's the
2d and it's not fine okay fine I don't
think that's objection of what I think
it should be a method sub-option yeah
yeah and then a performance goal to be a
high level switching of that and so this
next option molecule embedding I am
imagining should be have its name
changed because just because so so in
it's a method it's an option to just
give method options for generating the
coordinates for 3d it's the 3d analog of
structure diagram layout okay so where
do we put it in the method option and
why don't we say I mean why not say if
we're going to do that
maybe it's wrong layout 2d layout 3d
I think that would work yeah what should
we say aloud to Diop shion's if it's
going to be a list of options they're
like random seating arrow whatever
you know which is it is it is it the
case that what we really have is layout
2d method and as well as or layout 3d
method as well as potentially layout 3d
options which might be separate that's
definitely true so we have a few named
methods for for generating coordinates
and within those methods we have a lot
of sub options that that are options for
your library but remember that there's a
sub option so you know it sounds very
much more similar to you know how we
layer the methods in nd solve and you
said yeah I know it's like this oh yeah
typically like that yeah all right okay
fine so I mean if you don't check to
layout 2d and layout 3d is that
reasonable yeah I think so
I can it's not work okay okay so that's
molecule embedding alternate in
platforms
oh my gosh okay so you're saying I can
put in this weird thing is that right
you say and put that in and it was nicer
to him yeah and I assumed it was
supporting that an interpreter as well
so that is the plan I mean right now I
have and I have it set up as its own
function name two smiles but I don't
think it should be there all right I
think it should be an interpreter
wow that's pretty neat so if I say here
something like if I just give a string
like benzene or something it'll just
work okay what happens if I like to
benzene with a capital B I'll just work
what happens if I do what's the most
complicated molecule I mean something
where it has a name like caffeine that
isn't an IU pack name so it knows it the
absent parser has a lot knows a lot of
different styles of nomenclature it's
okay so how does it relate to the pawza
that we use in for chemicals right now
or are we using this one we're using
that in alpha right now okay fine
if you scroll over in the the other
notebook I include an example of a
really long name that opsin is able to
to parse into a chemical graph this
thing here yeah okay so if I say so what
you're telling me is if I say molecule
of that creature whatever that creature
is and then I try and you know tempt
fate and I say molecule plot 3d of that
right that that might so that might fail
or it might take forever but it is
affordable okay it took a lot of work to
make that affordable okay so it's a
unable to generate 3d coordinates for
molecule so the the random coordinate
generation failed in that case it didn't
so I created the yeah it created the
bounds distance matrix and try to
generate random coordinates that satisfy
it
and it's it's it did not secure so what
you're saying is that that it couldn't
find a configuration for that molecule
that made sense right I've actually had
some pretty decent experience though I
think this is too small this thing the
other ones were too big this is too
small it might as well go as far as it
can to be visible what do you do with
that with graphs Charles in terms of
sizing up like that when the graph is
very detailed
rolls
so I was a mute well well I don't know
butter for my head but we essentially
use I mean we rely on the fact that we
have the coordinate are not just if I
give a by us for a carry tree with a
with a thousand elements for example
right maybe a big messy thing okay so
why does that not I mean I guess that's
a reasonable size for that graph but
you're not going wider than that for the
graph right whereas here I do think it
will be worth well I don't know you can
always make it bigger I guess you can
always make it bigger Roger do you ever
thought about this I think yeah I think
we shouldn't make that super
sophisticated now I know we can return
to it ok finders write this message
unable to generate 3d coordinates so
that should be improved I mean I can
tell the user that they can call embed
molecule and give it a max iterations of
an extremely high number and then just
go for coffee or something like that and
you can you could generate some some
entity for the caffeine molecule or
something
never mind I'm just joking um what do
you seriously want to say there so what
is the point you can say what you're
really saying is the distance geometry
embedding failed or timed out it didn't
fail it timed out right through it
reached the number I set an internal
number of max iterations in it and it
ranged it so
to embed what's that it's really
attempts to embed successfully you know
trying it you know ten times or whatever
and it didn't succeed on any of them
right unable to find a consistent set a
fast statement 3d structure
after bababa
Asians or attempts I mean it's not
really iterating okay what's the option
that allows you to do it four more
attempts so it's a method option in so
right now it would be molecule embedding
goes to list max iterations goes to this
yeah we gonna call it iteration so are
we gonna call it max what do we call it
when it's just a sample like a Monte
Carlo or in numb where it isn't an
iteration because it's not an iterate
the point you're making Bob is that it's
not an iteration it just tries to get
correct
okay so what do we call that in other
places we're just trying again
I'm trying to think of something where
we do that
what about Monte Carlo what about max
what would we have that's max something
like that
max steps sounds like an iteration again
yeah this is a string thing anyway um
what about Max random seeds or something
like that because that's kind of what
it's doing
yeah I think we should just call it's a
string I think we just call it Mac so
tense
does anything have a restart capability
in the language maximum you know max
restarts or something like that I don't
think so you know there is an example of
that yes something like ping time has a
maximum great not set up here um
something like ping time or or yeah
there's a max retry type thing for let
me think um well let's try ping time
here yeah but max retries is very much
what this is doing no I understand that
I understand that you know in constraint
um where does that happen that happens
inside some kind of URL read
functionality and things I don't know
there is a if you send it out to the
core design mailing list somebody will
know we have this we have this thing
where there's a retry effort something
that does retries I'm not sure next rise
I don't know
tries attempts attempt sounds like it's
sort of pathetic and can't manage it
but I think there's a message like this
is a better message here make sense and
we could try and add some some thing to
say how to get it to do more attempts
does it have to anything to do with
continuous tasks I don't know I mean I
just plugged retry into the search for
the documentation and restart interval
came up for continuous tasks no it's not
it's it's for pinging servers it's why
when you ping a server and there's a
question how many times you retry for
the server maybe somebody on the live
stream knows okay anyway we can find a
word for this okay so by the way a
question on the live stream can we
compute the sanitary group or a molecule
I think the answer for right now is no
no the answer is yes oh that's more
exciting okay how do we do it I have to
relook it up because the molecule
structure changed from the last time I
implemented it and what does it return
does it return what about group objects
you actually know that there we we have
to sort that out still it returns the
Shirin fleece notation that chemists use
which is very similar to the Shirin
fleece notation used in the finite group
data collection but there are some
disconnects that we have to sort out how
bad are the disconnected so to speak
it's been a couple of weeks since I got
that email so I not too bad what is it
is it is it finite group data
yes finite group data the thing is the
assurance least notation is only used
for the crystallographic point groups
and there's a finite number of them yes
for molecules though they're not
restricted to the crystallographic point
groups you could have for example is
something with c5h symmetry or c12 h or
something like that I understand but it
doesn't have to be it doesn't have
translation invariance so it has
I mean it's not be is that the point
that it's not translation but that the
rotation axis is embeddable in 3-space
or not or a crystal in a crystal graphic
lattice and five fold and seven full
twelve fold rotations or no I understand
that's but yes they have to be they have
to be a translation invariant crystal
yeah yeah that's right yeah yeah where
this is just a free-floating molecule
okay yeah you know but but here we've
only got we've got crystallographic
groups crystallographic point group yeah
well so fair enough so we just don't
have the notation for a molecular group
so to speak but I kill a symmetry group
yes if we added that then I think we
could resolve all the issues well why
don't we do that because I mean that's
what would we call it molecular point
group wasn't molecular symmetry group
yes and then there also offers the
opportunity to get to non rigid symmetry
groups which have played a role in some
aspects of chemistry okay it's what I
was doing host doc um fair enough um
that would be an issue for Jose who did
the finite group data thing I talked
with with Jose he's he's interested in
getting I mean getting somebody like
like an intern to curate the the rest of
the the groups that we would need we
actually do have something hooked up in
the system right now if it's it's not
pretty though if you did symmetry
information of molecule of benzene its I
don't have any plans to move this one to
the system context but some molecule of
benzene and then symmetry information
with a capital s capital I know so not
so it's a function okay Wow
d6h and then it shows the I mean so this
all comes actually from from a library
so we're trying to implement that in
Wolfram language so we don't need to use
the library but this shows yeah so it
gives the the rotation elements the the
will see them planes of symmetry the
actual elements of the group right so
the the c2 act acts ease them it should
have it should have infinite planes for
the for the symmetry planes which there
will be a lot of them for this guy
that's the Sigma's or something that's a
mirror reflection and s6 is the
symmetric group one six elements no
that's an alternating reflection
rotation or an empress rotation is an
improper rotation you rotate a certain
amount and then reflect through a plane
orthogonal to the axis okay all right so
let's keep going here so this is ways to
get so you're hooking this up to
interprete and go from a smile so we're
gonna have to leave fortunate here and
let's just check whether there's
anything else for you particularly here
Roger um I guess not so long as Charles
can stay um okay
thanks Roger okay so what are we talking
about
so what is this what is that smiles what
do you do if you wanted 10,000 random
smile strings to play around with that's
that would be one that you could oh I
just random choice on okay I find those
to be helpful when I'm testing these
things up yes
okay where did you get the random smile
strings I mean you generated the random
spawn strings no from a resource object
that I so so from the quantum repository
they some researchers at the University
of Pittsburgh mates took it like about a
hundred thousand different molecules and
did quantum chemistry calculations on
them and then they made it publicly
available so it's a resource object do
we have it in the data repository yeah
neat okay is very cool by the way that
is ugly I mean it in terms of just the
visual appearance again you've got to do
something with that sizing agreed so
again some heuristics there don't ever
make the fonts bigger than a certain
size I can't make that small Reika so at
all and in terms of this when it gets
long it's this this crazy one here let's
look at what that thing looks like so
you're saying I see so if you say this
okay and it's wrapping somewhere there
right right I mean it doesn't have a
hell of a lot of choices here I think
this is acceptable what it's doing
I mean the other absolutely is wider but
what is the wrapping width here whatever
the default is for the summary box I
don't I don't have anything set there
but there's something that's going wrong
with the summary box is wider than mm-hm
the screen also for goodness sake I
already said this five-yard there : okay
but so this bizarrely is it seems to be
a summary box which does
know how wide the screen is so why don't
you ask the summary box experts what the
deal is with that yeah I have never seen
them taking this into account I mean if
you hit the edge of the summary box why
isn't it I don't understand why the
thing isn't well I don't know what it's
doing it doesn't I don't consider this
terribly important I think this is
definitely a weird corner case it's
making a choice to do some kind of
wrapping but why is that why is the
wrapping with the wrapping width what is
this
for convenience that's how I make a
molecule out of like an entity as I grab
that all the rules and I mean I don't
have to advertise that as a method to
create a molecule but that will work
okay okay that's cool that's very cool
so are you saying if I say how do I make
so let's say I'm say carry tree and and
how do i specify that it is okay hold on
I'm gonna about to find out this okay so
if I say carry tree of 40 or something
fine now I say but those are not carbon
atoms necessarily because they're
they're trivalent right in this bit rate
and so it might just say that those are
nitrogen's I think I made a very stupid
weird weird that is officially weird
okay so if I now say I mean it's cool
but yeah could you do molecule plot
please yeah
that's distinctly weird what the heck
did that do there so the layout
algorithm wasn't able to to lay them out
sufficiently or I mean that nitrogen has
a ridiculous valence that isn't it no I
think that it's placing two nitrogens
right on top of each other I think yeah
those have to be from nah that's not a
complete ring that middle one
well that's yes you know actually there
are no rings okay it can't be a ring
it's a tree right okay that makes a lot
of sense okay that's so that's quite
beautiful
except I'm confused by its it's weird
and random I mean is that a sensible
thing to do to just assume it's the
nitrogen if it's I guess you might as
well but couldn't it also be a carbon
with a bunch of extra hydrogen's hanging
off it could be there and maybe some
options could let one do that control
that capability right I mean yeah I
didn't quite know what to do there I
mean we could have what is the more
plausible thing seriously if I was
building you know I thought you know
back in the day people were building
molecules like dog Essene and so on
right and they were made of carbons
I mean before buckyballs were known yeah
I would expect it to fall Adam to be
carbon so okay so if it if it also but
then you would be okay with it adding
hydrogen's is that no yeah okay yeah
yeah I would okay so let's take the
first of these how do I get the actual
graph for this um can I just say graph
of that entity um Charles you should be
able to
why do you put a third bit acting fee we
did that I think on this this is the
product ID at home this is the person
built so something's gone wrong though
so you should check that but how do I
get the graph out of this I mean it
should have a graph property I would
think but okay so if I now say that's
pretty neat I mean if I can say molecule
and I'm really hoping it doesn't give an
horrible message molecule could not find
number of expected rings right that's a
that's that's a message I need to figure
out what the library is saying so in
that case I'm I'm I'm just giving the
the library message and I shouldn't do
that I know and it I'll remove that in
silence them what does it mean
I mean you what are you gonna say in
that case could not generate a molecule
from this thing what why couldn't you
generate a molecule looks like it has
you know everything's quadrivalent seems
beautiful to me
great I I think it's gonna be I think I
need to hunt down what the bug is and
I'm gonna find there's gonna bug in our
in the library we're calling okay you
know I think it's because you've got so
many cycles there it's ring finding
algorithm is failing and it's doing it
needs to find the ring so it knows how
to apply special rules for the distance
geometry so if I say molecule plot
percent 60 you think it's also gonna
fail that yep okay so now if I do this
one that should give you dodecahedron I
think oops
since 62 what nitrogen so sir nitrogen
is in there
so my heuristic for determining the font
size is really suboptimal is
oh that's about a bunch of giant ends
yes yeah okay
so why are you changing the font size of
these things why are you not I mean when
it went the font size needs to be have a
maximum right and it should never be
above the maximum right I so in the end
I'm calling font size scaled but that's
wrong that's wrong you should ask John
faults or Lou or somebody how to deal
with that they have some way of dealing
with font sizes that can be you know
scale up to a certain size now why does
it say that that's because it didn't
iterate it could not find them with the
right number of iterations is that right
right okay well we're not doing
fantastically here let's see what
happens if we try this Florine graph is
that with what I just tried yes what is
this thing here non-transitive
calligraph I mean I'm avoiding trying a
random graph because I think it's likely
working is very low given what we're
seeing here oh boy there's no way that's
gonna work right now no not even with
uranium okay well so we need better so
what are we going to do if the valence
is about four are we going to generate a
message or what are we going to do are
we going to randomly pick what's the
highest valence atom in the periodic
table generally six maybe eight and
those are really bizarre molecules
what what what element has valence six
sulfur for example can have up to six
right I mean can't xenon haven't they
been able to just throw tons and tons of
things on like Xena and reasonably well
xenon hexafluoride is the traditional
one that I know of from way back but
okay what are we going to do if the
balance is above four again given our
message it's rather unhelpful
so I think I could give a better error
message so in this case I apparently
just made it carbon even though it had a
valence of nine okay why don't we do
this in the method option for molecule
but couldn't we have something which
says something like I don't know I'm I'm
I'm you know atom types arrow and then
given a valence what the atom type is
supposed to be we could do that and it
would be just specifically for this case
of right of interpreting above graph so
so graph valence rules something that
makes sense that's a good idea yeah
now what about multi graphs and would
you know two edges represent a double
bond three edges a triple bond right
that would be that would certainly be a
more sophisticated better way of doing
it than what I'm doing here I mean and
also one could assume that the the users
might have filled out the properties of
their vertices so so right now if you as
so if you create a molecule and get a
graph from it I will populate the
properties of that graph what we do but
there are not standard properties so are
there changes know they would be string
values so but graph supports non-stop I
know it does yes yes this is getting too
ornate I think for this version why
don't we put in a golf valence rules and
why don't we have the default value be
one or two or three or four ROC and if
you want to put in something exotic for
higher ones as suppose you could I don't
think that's gonna be usable so one goes
to H and then everything else goes to C
or to throw if you want one go stage no
I think they should all go to by default
all go to carving because that's what
you would expect so I guess I was
thinking that with that example in the
other one the graph data octane that
that should produce octane
so right now that's basically all that
wrote does what are the what are the
graph data things are there that a
molecule like is there a fullerene there
is oh gosh this is huge this is
absolutely huge oh not so huge but but
yet we couldn't do this could we we just
tried this and didn't work we couldn't
generate a nice picture of it any even
in 2d right because of my no because
you're in craziness but it might be able
to do that it can't do C 60 I'm sorry
good your argument is we have um was I
was about to say I okay I do agree that
graph data of octane better actually if
you say molecule of graph data of octane
it really should generate that min okay
fair enough
I mean we could have the default be one
hour of hydrogen two three four arrow
carbon Bob do you think that's
horrifying
you know we could do that and those that
wanted strictly you know all carbons
could easily override that um fair
enough okay so I just send you this the
one thing that I think still is
outstanding is what you do with a
valence greater than four in your graph
I think you punt for now
Jason is there any kind of you know
generic atom that would or do we just
have too many bonds right so in the so
actually we have defined valence States
for a handful of atoms and if you so if
you try and make a five valent carbon
we will say that doesn't work but for
vast swathes of the periodic table we've
got no established valence rule soon so
I imagine if you just made them iron it
would make a horrible molecule but it
would it would pass the the valence
checks or it could make them tungsten
just for fun right but what is the right
generic item if there is a generic atom
what would it be well in in Wolfram
language it has to be tungsten I think
it's really random to do that
I mean it's amusing it's kind of a joke
well before with the transuranium
elements had names recently they named
them up till like 120 or something but
but he had these you know one deck
something something something some Latin
or Greek name that only goddamn was one
of them yeah is there some kind of
generic name that we could use for just
plain you know ultra valent hypervalent
or something like that that we could use
for this case Jason yeah I'll look into
that I'm taking notes here so I'll make
a one about I've valent I mean but now
we certainly could have the joke of
having it be tungsten well we could have
it fail either way it's fine this I
don't know that this will be quite ready
for so we can do protein but they're
great right so we can't fold them you
could if you can make that sequence it
would be very easy to make a sequence
that's too big to to plot realistically
okay but this is but for RNA can we do
it yeah so I've even set up the
autocomplete with this one so you would
do sequence molecule interest sequence
and then and then it gives like eight
different options of the types that are
supported like so RNA DNA or amino acid
sequence
in general in the future I think we
wanted okay yeah okay what were you
gonna say just dealing with
macromolecules is something that we
definitely want to do correctly it after
we established the molecule so in
general a protein or a macro molecule
you wouldn't want to to have every atom
be explicit in the list of vertices you
would want to do some kind of coarse
graining yeah all right we talked about
this before
yeah and so the molecule isn't the right
container for that in the end but you
can make a molecule with and there's
some special layout rules for 2d
rendering as well for the different
kinds you know RNA is a classic one
where there's you know special way of
handling that with a cross linkages what
the heck is this this is complicated so
right so so this exposed
takes us into to talking about patterns
we've got we can have atom patterns
whole mala substructure patterns or bond
patterns boy at the end of this were
actually going to be able to do I mean
this is this is a pretty nice way of
understanding chemistry hmm maybe I'll
even understand something about
chemistry after all these years okay
what does total connections mean that
means total bonds or what does that mean
right then why isn't it called total
bonds
I mean I kind of based those names off
of the the smarts
this kind of regex for four molecules
and so in the the they tend to call it
the number of connections but there's no
reason that we need to be I mean it's
like the vertex degree rate
but isn't that the bond number the
number of bonds yes as opposed to like
the valence or something that that
counts the the order of the bonds that's
just the total yet little connections as
to the total number of bonds so why not
call it total bonds I mean if there's a
double bond it counts for two yes well
no so not in this so the double bond
would count for two in in like the
valence oh I see so that's so I could
equally well here say atom valence arrow
blah right yeah I see and these are
things that you can put in that aren't
so those are just for queries right so
an atom with total connections goes to
one inside a molecule would make no
sense but it makes sense as a pattern
which is why I have the the pattern
molecule head but I don't know that
we'll we'll get to that today I don't
see the pattern molecule hug here it is
not in that list okay molecule q great
why isn't that just telling what the
head of the thing is why do we need a
molecule q is it to check whether it's a
valid molecule phrase doesn't check I
mean if we had xenon pentafluoride would
it tell us it wasn't about molecule or
not I don't think it would reject that I
mean it checks the molecule against the
rules that we've we have set up if it
comes back as molecule Q then I can do
lots of other things with it I mean
because it doesn't make something atomic
we need something like this fair enough
that's not a beautiful message
um okay we already looked at this yeah
just find out how to do this from the
front end team but it's really quite
beautiful what it's doing here so now
this highlighting business why does it
have double braces here let's see it
doesn't need to in that case you could
have one two three comma four five six
and it would highlight one two three and
a different color than four five six
very nice okay so that's magnificent so
is there a plot style option here that
determines those colors no so how and
why did Mike your plot suddenly go black
for everything else okay so yeah so any
atom that has a disk behind it I make
white in order to be able to see it and
so that was what so are from making them
white I I it's not a good idea you
should you should not change the colors
of the rest of the molecule just because
you're highlighting something okay I
mean this is a question for the design
group what we should do here and I also
don't agree with with them in just Oscar
design good what to do I suspect what we
should do is put some opacity on top of
this right and leave the color leave the
oxygen to be red mm-hmm I'm saying put
the disk with some opacity I think that
will work fine yeah I agree
that would be good for graphs Jason when
you highlight different parts you can
wrap an atom or an edge or a subgraph
with a style so you would say style and
then list your atoms and then comma red
or blue or whatever so maybe we could do
something like that here well so with
graph I mean you don't need graph plot
because you're putting all that
information inside the graph here having
well we could do is to model this off to
list plot okay so if I say list plot you
know one two three right and then I
could say style of 1 comma red okay and
I could say 2 is has a call-out you
should be able to use the exact same
code so so in in the second or you know
molecule plot where you're specifying
the the things that you're highlighting
that's where you would wrap so it would
be style list 1 okay yeah style I mean
that way you can determine how you're
highlighting them and the default should
be some opacity type thing ask Jeremy of
somebody in design group for this ok you
can make it look really good
what on earth is this contains structure
cue something I forgot to take out of
this notebook
I believe so we're not ready for that
yet rate molecule substructure cue or
something great sub molecule cue so to
speak so I think molecule position might
be the best one to go to next or go
along the list that's magnificent oh
what's that highlights ok what do you
mean by highlights here what is the
difference in highlights and the thing
you were showing before for molecule
plots why is that not a second argument
to molecule plot 3d just like it's on a
second argument molecule plots it so I
reused in alder notebook it is the
current the current syntax is for it to
be a second argument okay great so if I
now do this buckminsterfullerene thing
so this is something where it's
successfully doing ok so it's just
grabbing the coordinates from from the
knowledge base so it doesn't even have
to
have to do what to generate that's why
it has such a nice two DS okay so here I
just say smarts pattern all the smarts
partners what why am I saying smarts
back and can I just give the string no
so in this case it needs that to know
that what type of string it is that's
going to be another complicated story
what are you do wrong so I need the
right is that plot female no I I'm not
entirely certain why that why that's
broken at the moment okay so that's
smarts pattern it's like reg X for for
molecule substrate oh and I have a
Wolfram language version of that smarts
pattern
well it's a purple item right here so
there's what is a purple item no so so
what happened here is again like because
I added highlights I just always pray
which right I think here it might be
better to have a sphere that's slightly
larger than than I agree what I would do
to highlight these is have a nope
you know have a kind of a photos in you
know have a have a sphere around it
right a translucent sphere around it you
know and translucent tube around the
bones yes why not right so it's just
like it is literally a generalization so
in 2d it becomes a disc
you know translucent disc and in 3d it's
a translucent sphere this is lovely
functionality but we had people here
running out of time we actually probably
go on at a different time here let's
let's try to pick this up early next
we've clearly got what an earth is all
this stuff oh my gosh
great stuff these are okay those are
those are operations okay well fair
enough
we don't have some other things for
graphs could we put graphs we just have
a limited number of functions to change
them here delete edge delete bond erred
edge shared bond okay I'm just curious
here right so this would be for making a
molecule nearest function they use these
fingerprints that like that what do we
have in terms of a net encode if and for
neural nets for molecules do we have an
obvious way to do that so I've let's see
I've been looking at this past summer at
a few different like three processors
for for neural nets one of them which is
to make a vector or to make is what
we've been coming up with a couple of
this paths this past summer with an
intern that in this organ we're gonna
have a few nets to put on the repository
to deal with this you mean things like
no no Tyvek sort of things for molecules
right I so I don't know what that is but
I mean a couple of things that will take
them knowledge you mean something like
what did I promote kills that would you
meant no I meant note to Veck that's out
of Stanford also okay for taking a graph
and turning it into some kind of vector
representation for neural nets right so
so we've got we've experimented with a
few different of those and so one we
have one neural net that takes a
molecule and creates an image out of it
like a 2d 2d structure one of these 2d
structure diagrams but then encodes
chemical information in the the channels
of the image then we have another method
that just that uses the 3d structure to
to generate the input vector those are
the two that we've that we've
experimented with okay hey let me ask
you about the status of this chemical
drawing thing so you have a JavaScript
application that is doing this is that
right
right but it's it's still clunky there's
some issues it only draws diNovo it
won't take a molecule to start from is
one thing yeah also if you can end up
making mistakes and have an atom hiding
behind another atom or a bond hiding
behind another bond and you don't know
it until you try to import it until you
bring it back in and then it's not a
real molecule and you're getting error
messages those should be highlighted in
the drawing tool itself so you can
correct them right so for that we need
the drawing tool to actually communicate
with with with the wolfram kernel and
then also there's the fact that the the
container like the shippable container
that we have for this right now since it
since we don't want it to use your web
browser it's using a yes notice right
now it's but there's a special like
quasi browser that comes with that that
makes this thing the the packet that we
have the version that we are working
with right now is several hundred
megabytes because of that so that's
something we need to fix also doesn't
external evaluator allow you to evaluate
JavaScript code using a node.js server
right but I don't know how to use it
okay fine um okay well there's a lot of
magnificent stuff here um great okay so
look we clearly need we're gonna need
another couple of hours I think to go
through this so we should get that
shredder old and take it from there
okay yeah all right thanks to everybody
wait a minute somebody let me just look
at these questions on this live stream
how did it find a 2d embedding but not
3d because the 2d embedding is just a
diagram 3d requires actual realistic
Oh time positions I call hail from
grafton molecule pops a vertex property
can also determine the atom type yes
indeed from a vertex property in the
graph yes I agree
um okay
well thanks everybody to be continued in
a few days all right
see you later have a nice weekend
likewise bye